okay skip the rest of that terribly
entertaining video
hello everybody
hello uh do feel free to visit the
website the chap you did the art for me
he's awfully good he does a lot of stuff
like this this is the sort of um this is
the sort of graphics computer gameplay
when i was a kid aren't they awesome
uh loading time for a computer game was
what about five minutes
and made a noise that could wake in the
dead it was great
also don't ever put your computer game
anywhere near a magnetic source
otherwise you just lost your game
anyway let's move on
this is me bit about me oh i thought
yeah
i've been in working in it for quite a
while now i'm from the uk
um i've worked in a whole load of
different industries i've done
government um i've done retail i've done
manufacturing various things briefly i
was one of those contractors that your
mum used to warn you about and these
days i work for muller do they have
muller in denmark i don't know they're
pretty famous in the uk they make these
these yogurts yogurts with a fruity yeah
no i don't know but that's what i do i
make people sure people get yogurt which
is always good
so
i am going to talk today about being
lazy which i would argue is probably the
thing that has moved forward nearly
every technology on the planet because
at some point somebody sat down and said
this is boring how can i do it better
pretty much oh there's my twitter handle
by the way feel free i can bring that
back later follow me on twitter even the
unlikely event that anybody has a
question or ever wants to talk to me
ever again
uh
heaven knows
my wife doesn't always want to but there
we go all right
the uh the great
uh conflict of our time we've got two
men here well then they are both men one
of them's fooling no one
and one of them follows the rules does
everything by the book and the other is
the slacker the one who takes it easy
and just does whatever and of these two
men how many of them got to ride around
in a flying time machine and almost
sleep with his no don't do that one
don't do that one but the flying time
machine yeah
and honestly i am far too lazy for an
awful lot of the stuff that we have to
put up with encoding and that's kind of
what i'm what i'm looking at is a whole
load of techniques i've got for saving
yourself some time get rid of some
boilerplate get rid of some useless code
that's doing no one any good
now these according to me
are the phases of a project
which of these as developers because i'm
assuming from world developers i don't
know if that's true but i'm going to
assume it for the time being
which of these can we make any sort of a
dent on in terms of saving us a load of
effort and time well gathering
requirements is typically not us
designing a solution again typically not
coding yeah
and enhancements and of these by far the
thing that we spend most of our time on
is enhancements that is not the initial
development effort but every single time
you go back to the code base who has a
code base older than 10 years
yes most of you 20 years
still a lot of you
30 years
well okay fair enough i kind of there
were jobs when i could have put my hand
up but
my point is
initial development it might be a few
months it might be half a year it might
be whatever but it's going to be in
production for potentially 20 years or
more
and every single time you go back in
there there's a whole load of messing
around and
that is where the any application spends
the vast majority of its time and that
is where when you look at the whole life
of an application we can try and save
the most effort by writing code which is
incredibly easy to enhance
and what are the problems that can occur
that make it hard to enhance code well
unclear requirements that is between
yourself and whatever ba you believe in
project management issues again that's
down to your pm legacy code base on the
other hand
that's a problem we can potentially deal
with and one of the problems with legacy
code bases
is the fact that the code is flipping
unreadable most of the time
what does it do
this code this function is 2 000 lines
long it's called do stuff
it has
four levels of nested if statements and
calls to nested stored procedures in the
database i don't even know what it does
i don't know about anyone else but i've
had cases where there's been a box with
three rules and the business have just
said there's three rules in that box add
a new rule i said great well the problem
is the first rule split in four
different places the second one's half
in the database half somewhere else i
don't even know where the third one is
so yeah sure i'll just ram an extra rule
in there easy
so
i can't solve all of these problems but
i can at least try and uh suggest some
techniques that will will help us to
prevent this coming in the first place
so again according to me these are the
parts of a function
you've got the parameters there's stuff
coming in your return value stuff going
out but in the middle we've got these
two guys
and i would argue that an awful lot of
the problems that we see with functions
is where you get these guys modeled
together the code structure and the
business logic so what are these
well the code structure is the how am i
doing it
the business logic is the what am i
doing
if the business would ask you what does
this do the business logic is what you'd
answer with that is what it does
and what i would like to do is to try
and pull these apart as far as possible
there's a concept in audio engineering
called the signal to noise ratio
that is the ratio of the thing you were
trying to listen to to the background
noise the thing you're trying to listen
to is the album or whatever the voice
the background noise is the hiss on a
cassette or the rumble on a record or
the album on a justin bieber album
the thing you don't want to listen to
so
so how can we how can we achieve this
how can we separate out the signal and
the noise
so part one looking just at the the
micro level just at the smallest point
possible
what does this do you got five seconds
no
there's a lot of noise in there there's
a lot of noise now as it happens this is
going to a configuration file it is
trying to parse in the value into
something rational uh it is applying a
default
that's an awful lot of stuff that's an
awful lot of lines of code if i wanted
to add in an extra setting that is going
to be one two three four four about five
extra lines every single time this does
not scale up well
and anyone who's never run into this for
a while before they're gonna have to
spend a bit of time staring at this to
work out what it does
so i could throw in a um extension
method like this now is everyone good
with extension methods
good going to be a tough talk for you
otherwise
so
this is a nice simple little extension
method and what is it doing is attaching
to a string and saying give me a default
then doing the check to see is it null
or not doing a tripod or not as
appropriate depending on what it is and
return either the default or this you
could also have a version with no
default asked for and just return
default yourself depending on what
you're trying to do but the point is
it turns it into this
so what's that do same thing but you
could look at that and understand that
in five seconds most likely and how many
lines of new code do you have to add in
if you want to add a new rule one
sort of technically none because it's
all one line of code but sorter
but the point is even your manager could
look at that and roughly understand what
it does
anyone pretty much could look at that
and even understand that it's not doing
what it's supposed to do if someone's
put the wrong default in it's really
simple
and it reads somewhere close to natural
language which is great it's easy to
maintain and all we did was put in a
little extension method to hide away all
of that tedious boilerplate
now
extension methods get a bad rep but i'm
going to introduce my
um
commandments of extension method or when
i say commandments as always
it depends what you're trying to do
but this is roughly my guidelines for
when it's good to use extension methods
and you should
no business logic
business logic is the most important
part of any application that is what the
app is trying to do that should be right
up at the front that should be where
everyone could see it that should be
screaming out the first thing you open
the code base do not put
business logic into extension methods i
have seen people do this it is the road
to disaster
the extension method is equivalent of
code that is like the snuff action
figure from thundercats do you remember
thundercats yeah
so you have it you own it you don't want
to get rid of it you also don't want to
show anyone you've got it so you just
sort of pop it in a box at the back of
the code base
and it can exist but no one needs to
know that's extension methods that's
what goes in them that sort of code
keep them compact i generally try to
keep them online occasionally i have to
write more than one mostly i write them
to one i keep them as small as possible
discreet tiny units of functionality
works best that way if you start putting
too much in these things well then
you've got a potentially
dangerous bit of code that's doing far
too much at the back of your code base
that no one can see
keep them generic apply them wherever
possible to everything wherever i can i
apply them with t's as in generics so
they literally apply to everything i do
that as much as i can
keep them portable by which i mean you
should be able to take this box of
extension methods and drop them into any
project in your entire code base
we don't have a new get server at work
at the moment but we're working on it
and this is probably the sort of thing
that's going to go in our nuget server
something that potentially then that
could be consumed by all of our apple
applications across the estate so they
can all benefit
and use them just wherever there's
boring repetitive code get rid of the
code structure and hide it in these
things because who really cares
i don't
i made them useful i was told i did this
talk once some years ago and someone
told me that they've made an extension
method called is true
that is not useful
it's interesting
it's great that you took the time out to
do that but it is not useful
so
that's my rules
couple more extension methods that i've
used once in a while this is for parsing
if you use this you could potentially
turn any string into an array of arrays
and never need to bother splitting that
all out again and you just pass in the
line splitter field splitter there we go
easy there's probably some extra bits
and pieces you could put in there but
it's the sort of thing you can do if you
do it a lot
or if you find yourself doing an awful
lot of checking against both empty and
no just stick it in extension method
it's kind of
a little bit of a rule of thumb with me
once i start finding myself doing the
same thing two or three times stick it
in an extension method get rid of it i
don't really need to keep doing that
it's more lines of code than i need to
write
i kind of like this one i love
dictionaries dictionaries is actually
one of my favorite features in c sharp
they're brilliant they have some
terrible flaws but one of them is how
tedious it is to make dictionaries you
have to supply two different lambdas so
why not just make an extension ex uh
just
make it one single function call done if
it's a key value pair there's a fair bet
that i know which is my key and which is
my value so why am i needing to specify
this
and there's some others you can do it
with tuples you can do it with all this
stuff so that's yeah
something else i've done once in a while
make account dictionary so do a group
buy and then use the dictionary to sort
by the key and then tape account so
therefore you've got something you can
easily shove into almost any um
any report you care to write when you're
summarizing a whole data set
anyway that's some random examples of
the sorts of stuff
moving on from tiny little micro line
bits of noise let's move on to
structural noise
this is slightly larger stuff
this is something i used to do an awful
lot when i worked for an american
company so i am british and as such i
talk a lot about the weather
that is a cliche it is mostly true we do
we do um in the uk you can easily get
four different seasons in the same day
such is our weather we get about as much
rain as everyone else it just sort of
happens at random through the year
so american my american colleagues would
say things like it's 100 outside now i'm
not going to do the accent because like
i can't and it'd be embarrassing but the
point is that uh i work in centigrade
and 100 centigrade don't think oh my
gosh that's the boiling point of water
how are you all alive
but of course this is fahrenheit
which is what i don't know is about 32 i
don't know i don't really care but um
the conversion the conversion between
fahrenheit and centigrade is multiplied
by 9 divided by 5 plus add 32 course it
is of course it is and then convert it
into a string when we're done
and that's a lot of there's a lot of
wasted code there you've got these
little temporary variables now i could
turn this into one great big long line
of course that would be lovely but then
it'd be unreadable
um this is readable but i've had to
waste all of these little local
variables now imagine that this function
was a thousand lines long there and this
was at the beginning well var a still in
scope at the top sure that's just um
what is that's a decimal that's fine but
imagine it was a complex object staying
in scope all that time we're just
wasting space
so how can you get rid of this best
little extension method you never
realized you needed this is map i've
heard this called all sorts of things
but uh map is as good as anything for
now and this attaches to t input which
is a generic so it's everything
and we take in a function which converts
input to output and it gives out every
so whatever it is
take your input shove it in the function
pull it out again
pass it on
it looks like this
there we go
all those local variables gone
and there are some further benefits
through this which i haven't got the
time to talk about now if you get into
functional programming this is a
structure called a monad
and there's all sorts of funky things
you can do inside this map to uh to save
yourself errors and all sorts but for
now this is nice and compact
we can kind of ignore the map because
it's it's just the same thing there and
uh we've saved ourselves all those local
variables plus we could turn the whole
function into an arrow function now
which means we are discouraging anyone
from ever adding a whole ton of useless
functionality into this thing i like my
functions to say small to the point and
accurate to whatever the heck they're
called
i don't like to encourage people to
start adding new stuff in
by the way this is how you might um also
do some logging in the middle of that
stream this is a tee you just do it like
that there you go stick an action in the
middle now you can log if you want so
that is just going to log whatever that
value is there which why would i do that
but you can you get the idea
how about this is another situation
where there's a whole load of tedious
boilerplate to be written pre-pending i
don't know why i want to do this but i
want to do this so i'm going to say
hello to whomever whomever i've just
gotten the date from the database and
i'm going to call two people the first
appears to be the devil so that will
give him value and presumably say hello
whatever his name is stephen
and then the other is 616. uh the
neighbor of the devil
what's his name i don't know george so
but the point is 616 returns a null and
we're trying to pre-pend and pass in a
null now what happens when you do this
explosion
now
you could add in a whole load of
boilerplate noise like this where we're
checking against default and then
deciding whether we've done d
and all we've done is turn this lovely
elegant little function into something
which has got flipping tons of extra
lines that just exist to protect us from
death
or stick in another extension method
like this now the the equality comparer
there looks terrifying it is just the
generic version of checking against null
because not everything actually in a
generic necessarily defaults to null
integers don't booleans don't you get
the idea
and this is just doing that null check
for us so there we go
potentially never need to do another
null check again all of that is now
wrapped inside that functionality
if i call this do not if not null then
um
that's descriptive
it says what it does and then whatever's
inside will only be executed if it's
safe to do so super duper
there's all sorts of other ways of doing
that i'm keeping it relatively simple in
this talk
dictionaries like i said one of my
favorite things i love them i love how
they love the quick look up i love the
lovely elegant syntax
uh and as anyone who is into the same tv
series i am might have noticed i am also
into the tv series doctor who
i don't know whether we have doctor who
here uh if anyone's unfamiliar yeah it's
the best tv series in the whole world it
actually is it's in the dictionary if
you look it up anyone says otherwise
so i'm going to do a look up here to see
uh to get myself a list of some doctors
so
if i got dr juan out of this function
we'll get back william hartnell the boss
and if i put in a hundred because it
hasn't been yet there will be there will
be uh but if they looked into 100 and he
put that into dictionary anyone know
what happens if you put
a
look up in a dictionary which is not a
key that it currently holds in or no
sorry
exception explodes why
that's ridiculous but there you go it's
what it does
fine what can we do about this
well this is my solution this for me is
how you make dictionaries useful again
because i don't like the explode if not
found thing that causes defensive
boilerplate to be written and i don't
like that it's boring
so
what i'm doing here is using a funk
now uh as a filter
so i'm not actually returning a value
out of this extension method i'm
returning a funk and the funk is a
filter it's a filter that says you asked
me what you want i'm going to go away
into the dictionary have a look if it's
not there i'll tell you and if it's
there i'll tell i'll pull it back
and that's it we don't need to worry
anymore about having to do the null
checks ourselves because this guy will
do it for us it's the filter that stops
us from doing the thing that would cause
the explosion
all it means is that you have to uh
now the the actual lookup is now a funk
and we use curly brake we now use the
curved brackets instead of the square
ones other than that it's still a
dictionary for as long as this func
remains in scope the dictionary remains
in scope
so that's good that's pretty good so now
we get a don't know back if we tried to
ask for doctor 100 that's great that's
wonderful
but we could still do better
so i am going to
imagine i want to get a whole set of
doctors now for some arbitrary reason i
want to get the first third and fifth i
don't know why i want to do that but for
the purposes of this explanation that's
what i want
great
and i could create my array and i could
call uh dd.getdoctor three times with a
one or three and a five
now there's still an awful lot of
boilerplate there we can do better than
this
so there we go we could have an indexer
let's cut down some of it indexes are
good a little static function well
that's static but there are little
functions there there we go that syntax
is much nicer isn't it it's not bad
but did you know
did you know you could put params inside
um and index it because you can
now have oh is that there we go have a
look at that
that is functionally identical to the
first one if i put params inside the
index i just literally call the uh call
the object and go one three five there
inside that's it
it does all three lookups for you in
fact we're doing them in a select so
we're still getting the benefits of
using link
that's awesome
and that's an awful lot less code than
uh the first version
okay
this is one of my pet hates i'm hoping
none of you are doing it but until i see
people
stop doing this i'm going to carry on
doing this
so
we're going to write ourselves a
function which is going to go away and
grab some data generate a report
transmit the data or maybe make a
transmission if uh if there's no data
there great let's unit test this thing
because we're good people
so positive test we can put some data in
yeah those lines of code are covered
we'll do a negative test there was no
data that lines covered
we'll do uh some exception testing
that's good great we've got 100 unit
test coverage this is marvelous so we
are pretty solid on our function
but then there is a rumbling on the
ground you look down at your coffee you
notice like that scene of jurassic park
that it's quivering like this
and you look up and notice your
unusually tall boss towering over you
and asking you for prop 2 to be made
into a function well what's the easiest
way to do this
yeah good this video works time there we
go
copy
and
ah so easy
yeah
feels good done it
is that the best way to do this
well yeah sure it's easy it's quick
but then what about prop 3 what about
prop 4 what about 105 you know
i worked in an application many years
ago for an awfully important company who
i'm not allowed to talk about but it's a
lot less interesting than it sounds
trust me
but anyway
they had a rule base that had to be
created every year and every single year
they took the old rule base it was quite
a long rule base and there'd be a couple
of subtle changes but they had to
maintain each rule base simultaneously
so we'll just copy the old one paste it
into the new one maintain this alongside
it make a couple of changes and then
maintain it there's about 20 30 of these
things and then i had to look at this
and i said hang on there's a whole lot
of bugs in this one
okay that's the latest one i just
noticed all these bugs let's have a look
at the one before that's got all the
same
oh
okay
uh i had to go and edit a whole load of
years all at the same time because
everyone had just trusted the folks
before them to have done a good job and
they just replicated the same bugs again
and again and again and again
so that copy and paste job maybe didn't
save you quite as much as you thought
that's a lot of lines of code to
maintain simultaneously and what if
someone comes up with a really super
duper clever idea one day and
you're gonna apply it to all of them i
don't think so
so i don't know what the proper term is
for this i call them donut functions
this is my solution
turn that guy into a private
which is not a rank in the army
pass in a funk
which turns you someday to whatever that
is i see a selector that's telling you
which field now it could be an end time
assuming they're all in they don't have
to be and then just
apply it there so basically i'm using
the funk
as a whole
in the middle of the function to apply
the bit that's different
and i can do that every time i can make
that as complicated as you like you can
pass in many funks if you like but the
point is
i'm only ever writing one and i'm using
the funk to fill in the blank
easy i can now write as many um as many
of these functions as you like and
they're literally just lambda
expressions every single time
if someone finds a bug in the root
function everyone benefits
and to be honest if it were me i
probably wouldn't even bother to um
to expose pro one and prop two separate
functions like this i might even
consider just literally generate average
report and then just expose the lambda
out why not saves a whole load more time
but it depends as always what you're
trying to do but the point is funk see
your friends
there we go that's
that's just in case the video didn't
work
another place i use this is things like
i know i'm not the biggest fan of entity
framework it is a bit like getting a
great big old sledgehammer to crack a
nut
but um
it has a load of boilerplate that if you
don't follow you can end up with some
terrible problems and amongst them make
now
that's a terrible idea don't do that
i didn't realize i'd left that in that
don't do that
uh but anyway the point is that you want
to put a using around your data store
you want to call it two array at the end
don't call two lists you want to call
the two array at the end uh otherwise
you're exposing out stuff that really
shouldn't be seen outside of the guts of
your database layer
you could do all of this with um sorry
that by passing in i queryables just
write a func i queryable to my queryable
you can expose that out and then for the
time that this funk runs
it'll run here
and then for the ter within this funk
you're basically exposing the query to
be whatever that's where people can
write their great big long link queries
to query the database and then two
arrays automatically called by the
method at the end so you can be sure
that whatever comes out of it should be
safe
anti-funny so
this is another sort of thing that we
might do quite a lot validation
functions
so i am validating your username
there's a set of rules that i've
arbitrarily decided on because of course
it can't be empty he can't be uh shorter
than two or longer than twenty it can't
be just in bieber because it can't
now my daughters are six and eight
thankfully they have not yet discovered
much of an interest in him and i am
doing my best
um
i i told my youngest that uh kate bush
is cool because she has the same name as
you that's cool seems to have worked
don't tell her
okay but anyway same repeated
functionality again and again early
returns false early return false and
then a final return true how can we wrap
all of this into a structure that we can
reuse and chuck the boilerplate in the
bin like this
that's an all that's a link method
link is absolutely one of the great
greatest inventions ever in c sharp
um along with dictionaries and record
types but that's a talk for another time
and the all goes through every item in
the array
and
every it asks for a funk which has to
evaluate to boolean and every single one
of these booleans must evaluate to true
if any of them don't then just cancel
the whole thing out and return early
with a false which is exactly the
structure of what we just did so you
could just write this
there we go
isn't that an awful lot nicer to look at
a couple of benefits it's really concise
it's easy to read again you could show
this to an awful lot of people who are
not terribly technical and they probably
underst they might not know what this
means but it doesn't really matter
because all they're really interested in
is this you could even hide it if you
wanted to in a little local function or
something just to give it a friendly
name that would be fine
but you get the idea and once again it
stops anyone from putting more into this
function and really belongs to them
there
because i do not like long functions
is another example this is another way
of doing my conversion
from uh fahrenheit celsius you could
stick an aggregate now if anyone knows
aggregate but aggregate seems to be one
of those great unknown features of c
sharp it's brilliant
um but it just
basically does the same sort of
principle as my map you you start with
something and just do a series of
conversions here's the running total
here's what we're doing with the current
item just keep changing the current item
to the new running total again and again
and again but basically what you get out
of it is this
same basic idea and now we can do away
with the maps if we like
so
this again is um saving us an awful lot
of effort
did you know you could also put um
yeah so this is a what you call a
factory we're looking at types
and generating the child type well did
you know that you can also put types as
the keys of a dictionary because you can
so you could do stuff like this
you could
switch in a dictionary based on type now
come to think of it this is probably a
little update if using c sharp eight
you've probably got better things you
can do now but this slide was written
before those sorts of stuff uh those new
features with the new pattern matching
were brought in so but still this option
is available to you and look i look at
the default again look at that
right
being lazy
with innumerables i like innumerables
too any rewards are like me because
they're lazy
and innumerable is not data that's the
most important thing to know about an
enumerable it is not data it is a
pointer to data all the numerable is is
a little box that says that way
and that's all an enumerable is
and it's got two buttons one that says
spit out the current one and the other
one that says move to the next one
numeral don't even know how many there
are
all it knows is this one next one
and that's cool
if you wait as long as possible
with actually evaluating your
innumerable into something solid like an
array
then it remains unenumerated
so this is so this is this is what our
numerable looks like now
i am aware i'm not very good at drawing
i do my best but still i've improved
but um all it is pointing at is like now
imagine that we wanted to amend this
array
but without actually enumerating it now
this is trivial this is just like i
could make those cars if i wanted it
does not matter but imagine that each
one of these was a giant complex object
maybe it's an entity framework lookup it
could be something massive and it could
be an ex
rather than just being simply moved to
the next item in array it could be an
expensive operation that has to be
performed or if that's the case
amending that requires you to
force it to become a concrete object do
whatever those operations are just in
order to change the third item and then
what if you don't need it later
where you've just defeated all the
benefits you got from your lazy loading
so this is a way of amending an array
without actually amending it
still there we go
yep
so
we're pointing out we could what am i
doing here
right
there we go
like this
i call it adjust and again it's kind of
like a filter it's a filter that sits
between the enumerable
and
so you've got your new bubble that
you're looking at and the one on the
actual solid data on the other side and
i've stuck this structure in the middle
and this structure is a select now
select returns an enumerable so select
does not actually evaluate to anything
until we've actually enumerated it so by
adding this select in the middle like
this we're again using a func like a
filter and saying
here are some conditions
under which we should think about
replacing the current item
and
should we do the replacement or not
now it sounds like you're doing a whole
load of stuff all at the same time but
you're not you're not
a select only evaluates when you need it
so if you do
for example select then select then
select then select
those don't actually execute in the
order you think they don't go do all of
the stuff in this one and then do all
the stuff in that one they actually go
one two three four like that
so
you can call it like this with your
numerals in the middle but it's not
actually doing anything
so when i call array a
there we go that's an array now array b
there
right now if the compiler was on this
line right here
array a hasn't changed nothing's been
done literally nothing has been done all
you've done is define an operation that
you might want to do sometime in the
future
same here when we go here still nothing
done
but what i've done is put in a
description
of the sort of changes i want to do in
the future
now when you actually try and enumerate
c what you'll find is it will actually
say okay this says go to b i'll go here
this says go to a i'll go here grab that
go here go here okay no adjustments to
be made i'll just return you an a then
and that's how that works
i wouldn't do but these guys that's just
a car but again if it's important that
you try and reduce the amount of um
array
enumeration of the enumerable that
you're doing
this isn't a technique you can use
there you go has it in a rather badly
drawn diagram so imagine it is a series
of filters
each call to adjust is like sticking a
filter between the enumerator and the uh
the final array at the end
another thing you can do this is
goodness me they're on to me run
right what if i wanted to check for
contains consecutive numbers that is one
num a number that's one higher than the
other spoiler there's one
so yeah
you can't actually compare innumerable
the same um items that are consecutive
can't be done
you can do that uh if you converted it
to an array but once again then you've
busted your uh
you've enumerated and as such you've
lost your lady lazy loading benefits
so
the way that you can do that is you can
crack open the numerable because this is
the engine that runs underneath the
innumerable
oh good to me i needed that
okay
underneath an enumerable is something
called a numerator and the enumerator is
that thing with the two buttons on it
this is the thing that actually drives
the innumerable if you crack this open
you can make an enumerable which behaves
in any manner that you want you want it
to every single iteration return the
same item twice sure do it that's how
you do it you can make an innumerable
behave any way that you want
now what i'm doing is is creating an
extension method i'll call any but this
time i've got a funk which i'm passing
in which is t t bull
um
that is the current item the previous
item are they the same or not
and this is how you use an enumerator
move next is the thing that says go to
the next one now an enumerator starts at
position minus one
so by default if you try and call
current which is to get the current item
out of any numerator when you haven't
started you'll just get an error it'll
be null so you have to move next move
next returns true
if there is another item or false if
there's no further items
so what this is saying is take my
enumerable
move next that is go from position minus
one to position naught
and then um call my n e which is to say
pass in this which is the enumerable
just pass it around or the enumerator
sorry
pass in the functioner again and
this.current so i am moving to position
naught taking current
and then passing into the next step bear
with me
and this is my actual thing this is the
actual function that's doing that check
against consecutive
once again we're saying move next so
we've all ready to
pulled out the first item we've got it
in this hand we've popped it there
that's current
we're going to move next again so we're
now at position one
and then we're going to say run the
function i've got position naught in
this hand i've got position one here pop
them into the function are they true
well great they will return true done
otherwise
we'll call ourselves again this is a
recursive function but this time i am
taking the current item and passing it
in as if it were the previous so what
we're doing is sort of juggling like
this going
past the current back to be the next
previous and eventually if there's no
more out of move next then we just
return false
oh
that was terribly complicated but it
looks like this
all it's doing is
compare the previous item with the next
and we can run through every single item
in there and check with any of them
where the was it y equals x plus one
they come
there probably needs to be a master apps
in there to be honest if i were being
really accurate with this but it's fine
it'll do
attributing how we're doing no we're
doing fine i'm doing fine today good
stuff
excellent so
to return back to doctor who because i
generally do as a warning if you ever
see me again i will talk about it at
length
uh just try asking my opinion of season
13 it ain't weren't good but anyway
some episode data for doctor who this is
a csv and we want to parse this into a
data structure because i don't know
we're running a report or something
whatever and this is based on i think
season 12 as it happens those are the
episodes the titles blah blah fine no
worries
can write ourselves a quick little
parser no trouble at all
hunt me i can pass this around maybe
generate a csv maybe generate report it
doesn't matter but the point is fine but
then we look at the data for season 11
and we'll see that is subtly different
you see there
that's the number of the episode within
the season
that's the number of that same number
but this is the number of
the story number of doctor who overall
counting all the way back to the first
episode in 1963
because i don't know they must have been
using a different data structure that
year
this is a silly made-up example but i'm
sure we can all think of similar things
where the data structure has changed
over time but we have to deal with this
so sure we could there's all sorts of
ways of dealing with this here's the
super simple one yeah you could copy and
paste the function but don't do that
um but this is one way you could use a
dictionary and you could use a
dictionary which is going to get you a
funk out of it that's a method nothing
wrong with that i would be proud enough
of that
so
store all the different converter
functions inside the dictionary use an
enum to say which season is it and then
get yourself the correct converter and
then feed that into something that's
fine nothing wrong with that
we could do better
could do better
uh
yeah that's that's my parser that's how
i'd use it so yeah split on now it's
always environment new line we're using
commas to split on the field so but what
if that and then just pass in the
converters so there you go past the
season into the converters
easy
but we could go better we could look at
attributes
attributes is one of those awesome
features that no one seems to use very
much but attributes are pretty cool
attributes are tags that you can apply
to code if you've ever used mvc you've
probably seen attributes it uses them
quite a lot and you can make your own
and it is literally as easy as that
there you go i've made myself an
attribute
and
all you have to do is tell it what data
you want to pass into that
so there we go look at that
what i can do
is create an abstract of episode data to
say that uh there's the title the season
number episode and so on and then i
could use attributes to say which
position within the csv are they
here's the season 11 data which is
actual instance of episode data and i'm
saying the season number is applied
there in
the tag at the top so that's an integer
that i can use to pass into things and
then i can say the csv here is in
position one
and down here the title is now in
position two in the season 12 data
there we go we just have to write
ourselves one super duper complicated
function to do this you only do it once
it can look a bit like this i'm not
going to dwell too much on it because
frankly it's ugly
but you only have to do it once
that's the simple one that's just the
getting the season number the attribute
off the uh the classes getting attribute
of class is quite easy
you just pretty much do it like that
and you can go there we go
getting the attributes off a property
a lot harder looks like that that's
pretty flipping ugly not gonna lie but
there you go that's how you do it in
case you're curious i had to go all the
way down to breaking funks into
expressions
fine i did it i flippin did it
it's using some reflection too so if um
one of your overriding concerns of your
business is performance this probably
isn't the very best but honestly
99.9 percent of us are never gonna
notice
and whenever people come to me we say
well that's not real that's not the
optimum performance that's yeah the
thing is what costs more
about two weeks of your time or one
round trip
i'm
gonna bet the ram chip's a lot cheaper
so just sure and especially these days
when we're all going zuri and cloudy and
awse and so on someone just has to go to
a computer press a button there we go
it's running faster now so
is it really
and that's that's how i'd use it so yeah
again
it's not the uh not the prettiest of
code
but what it means is i've written a
single generic episode parser
which can have a
dynamic
property used with in an attribute to
determine what is the season number
where in the csv can i find the title
and now the number of episodes is
hard-coded there which
it's not strictly true but we'll go to
that another day and then where's the
writer which is just x3
but oh my goodness we've got more
complicated stuff when we start going
into old data what if um
the writer was in different places there
we go we could just add in season 10
then we've got a couple of different csv
positions but it's just the same basic
idea
even if older data does go and rearrange
the fields we just use the csv position
attribute again
easy
every single time we get the data in a
slightly different format we can handle
it and this is just passing integers
around you can pass anything into an
attribute
you can pass a function to an attribute
if you really want to there's all sorts
of things you can do i wouldn't do that
though but um
yeah whatever you need in there you can
pop it in it's not a problem
you put the line delimiter in there what
if the really old data doesn't even use
uh commas and new lines there you go you
can just put it in the attribute
right
so your entire of your um
your entire of your season 10 parser
class consists of
two properties and a load of attributes
you could tell the boss i spent all day
on this
i'm just you know so like flipping
overworked and uh go watch um for
stranger things fall for a bit
i didn't say that
right
that's it that that worked out pretty
well any questions at this point
this is
anybody
going once
going twice
okie dokie i'm hoping that you're so oh
sir
readability sir
yes
as in uh so forgive me so are you
meaning like um so like my little
parsing attribute thing getting a new
user like say one of our office juniors
to come in and look at that it's a good
question yep so the question is looking
at that like attribute parsing thing
that was an ugly bit of code not gonna
lie
what about your your junior members who
are still learning c sharp and
how they're gonna cope with
i would argue that they don't need to
look at it
i would argue that your your young your
junior members of staff
mostly we're not going to give them that
sort of level of task at least at first
that's something they're going to build
up to
we'd probably ask them to do that
and they don't need to understand how it
works
this is the beauty of these sorts of
bits of code we can hide away all the
complexity and they don't really need to
know how it's working under the surface
because who cares really
if all that the the task was simply go
and write like the um the season two
parser and there's a couple of
differences they've got enough skill to
do this
uh as long as there's no new attributes
in there but uh if we've written this
thing well enough it should handle
anything so i would argue that uh sorry
where am i going to work
you said i'm getting a new job where
should i work can i work with you
sure i mean that's that's where you need
a more senior member of staff to
potentially although if you've been a
good boy and you've unit tested it
you've got that at least hopefully so
you i would never say do not write unit
testing for extension method you should
or at least by usage if nothing else so
you've got your unit test i mean i
probably could have written it a bit
more sort of split out and a bit more
logical than i did but i was just doing
it for demonstration purposes i'm not
really necessarily going to throw that
into production i'd probably put
now i'm big into functional programming
so i'd probably let a lot of other data
structures in there that would do some
other stuff but again that's a talk for
another day
but um yeah i would probably try and
write it a little more split out a
little bit more logical but
still mostly i would stand by my
argument that um
someone new is probably just going to
use the surface level and as they grow
within the company they'll start then
moving into the deeper levels of
and probably any reasonably competent
engineer could probably pull apart what
i did it was
i didn't do anything really crazy in
that uh that attribute parsing thing
that was mostly based on examples on the
microsoft website and how to mess with
with attributes it is a bit ugly though
it's just the way it is as soon as you
start messing with reflection things can
get pretty nasty pretty quick which is
why i use it sparingly but it depends as
always what you're trying to do so i
hope that answers your uh
no
any more for any more
sir you mentioned that you should not
put the business logic
yes
okay
so the question is why should you not
put business logic into extension
methods one second sorry
oh my throat feels like there is a
cactus in it
right that's better
um
so reason being extension methods exist
to hide things that is their purpose
they exist to make things go away
and by i put things in extension methods
that i don't want to see things that are
unsightly or tedious
business logic is the most important
part of your code base there is nothing
in your code base more important
than the basically the code that tells
people what this code does that should
be right at the front that should be
where everyone can see it
i have worked in a company where some
crucial business logic was hidden in an
extension method i didn't even notice it
was there for ages i just saw like you
know line one it does this line two it
does like line three it just went crazy
what
and it took me a while of staring to
realize there was an extension method
that they'd added in because the beauty
of extension methods is they're they're
invisible really they don't you won't
necessarily even realize their extension
methods they're a way of hiding stuff
i think they're brilliant
i think they have their uses and the
best thing you can do with them
is basically just like sweeping dust
under the rug you know it's like it's a
way of getting rid of stuff you don't
want to see but you shouldn't hide
business logic that's important
if the business come to you and say we
want to adjust the business logic you
want to know like that where is it i
know where the business logic is there i
will change it and adjust it i don't
want to be hunting around my code base
trying to work out where on earth it is
i have i've worked some pretty awful
places or it was hard to find
where the logic was
and it turned development efforts that
should have taken an hour or two into
weeks of work
because it was unclear where the
important code was
um so i hope that is yeah
any more for any more
the gentleman's point was that uh you
might put something in an extension
method that would be something you'd
expect microsoft to do in the future
sure i'd love for them to i would love
for them to flip and change the way
dictionaries work
um i don't there's anyone from microsoft
here but if there is i'll i'll say that
to write to them because i love
dictionaries but that explode if not
found thing is ridiculous
but i agree with you yeah i mean a lot
of the stuff that i've put in there i
would love to see that go into micro
into dot net at some point
um
so yeah good point um but
i would probably try and keep to that
sort of level
i wouldn't put anything specific to my
business in an extension like that in
any even if it's a bit of sort of even
if it's not literally business logic
even if it's just a little bit of
logical branching that's unique to my
business i still wouldn't put it in
extension method that's too distinctive
to us i'd only ever write an extension
method i could literally throw anywhere
in the world
so sure i i agree with your point
um anymore we've still got another 10
minutes
once going twice
okay well thank you very much and also
um if anyone's interested there's my
twitter again no this isn't my twitter i
am writing a book for o'reilly if anyone
is interested this is on functional
programming if you scan this thing here
o'reilly will give you a month free on
their platform it's awfully nice of them
so feel free please it doesn't cost me
anything
so go for it why not
if also if anybody is willing to spare a
little time we are looking for proof
readers for my book
uh i'm running about four or five
chapters at the moment so if anyone has
any free time and is willing to give a
few review comments i'd be awfully
grateful come have a chat with me send
me a message or whatever
um
but other than that thank you very much
oh